[Music]
this past november marked a year since
the passing of former zappos ceo and
entrepreneur tony shea shea who would
have been 48 years old tomorrow helped
revitalize much of the fremont and
downtown las vegas area now the downtown
alliance is hosting a celebration for
celebration of life rather for him
madison kimbrough is live downtown
tonight with a look madison
the celebration of shae's life started
around 4 this afternoon right here on
7th street and fremont right near
container park which is one of many
projects in the area he helped
revitalize this celebration honoring his
life will also feature an art and car
showcase food trucks and entertainment
all throughout the night the retired
zappos ceo passed away in november of
last year he died of smoke inhalation
from a house fire in connecticut over
the thanksgiving holiday we spoke to
some people here in downtown about their
thoughts on shea's impact on the city
and how they have seen it grow with his
guidance
it's sad it's sad seeing and you know
losing someone for the that help the
community out so much just because
not a lot of people do that and when
someone like that passes away it leaves
a mark you know like i've been here for
over 17 years
and seeing container park being an empty
lot to becoming what it is it is crazy
to think about
fremont street experience plans on
airing a one minute video they produced
celebrating tony shea's life at 8 p.m
prior to their viva vision show which is
free for all to come out and enjoy we
plan on being out here all night
covering the celebration of shea and
hope to talk to the downtown alliance
about the process and the time that went
in to planning this event that you're
looking at right behind me it's going to
be a great night reporting live in
downtown madison kimbrough live local
now